j'espère que tu n'en auras pas ouais, j'espère juste que
tu n'auras pas trop d'insectes
ouais j'essaie de
les manquer garçon cette semaine il n'est pas très grand regarde-
le ouais c'était mieux
hier
ouais un
joli peu de poussière qui
monte  c'est sympa comme ça tu pouvais vraiment le
voir euh
ouais chaud et sec
ouais ce L
Sky c'est cet autre gars ici qui fait
son propre truc pour aller au quatre ensemble
ouais nous irons au quatre ensemble ouais
ce type est juste en train de nettoyer  Coins, le
gars du coin met la maison à droite
tu veux ajouter un plan ouais ouais
comme ça et sans Ciel ok je
vais contourner celui de devant tu
vas prendre un virage à gauche et ensuite tu
vas euh ok tu auras  eux en ligne
ouais, j'essaie de ralentir si nous pouvons, j'essaie, il
arrive vers
nous, il a
presque fini sur ce SPI,
ils vont bien, je vais devoir y aller ici,
ouais, il y a trop de vent dans ma queue alors
nous y
voilà.
ça va ralentir si nous pouvons nous ralentissons
aussi lentement que possible
numéro
deux, ils finissent le terrain ouais ouais c'est bon,
laissez-les aller à celui d'à côté,
nous le finirons avec eux,
nous prendrons le shs pour
cela, nous  Je vais traîner un peu ici, d'accord,
garde juste la vitesse,
Jim Corner, l'homme qui vient
ici,
hé regarde là, hé toi, qu'est-ce que c'est très
vite, hé, tu
veux envoyer, j'en ai deux, euh, deux, euh, ouais,
des bandes-annonces ici, ouais, deux, ramasse Ma
oh, pourquoi ne pas faire un tir ?  du
haut à droite
jusqu'au dessus, je dois peut-être le faire,
je suis comme incliner l'hélicoptère,
à quelle
heure juste pour obtenir
ça, veux-tu être au-dessus de
cela, ok, retourne dans le vent
ici,
eh bien, nous faisons demi-tour, nous devons prendre  la
fin du sera probablement plus facile et
mieux, il y aura plus de camions qui arrivent
ici ouais c'est vraiment sympa, ils oh
le troisième je pense qu'ils n'en ont que
deux qui travaillent dessus maintenant
ouais tu fais quelque chose
ouais comment ça se passe ouais excellent excellent
reste juste ici si tu peux en
descendant ouais ce sont les deux
derniers veulent le finir comme ça ouais
ouais juste tu le finis comme ça ouais
ok hein c'est
fini ok eh
bien c'est le pote qu'est-ce qu'ils
font il clique juste pour resserrer n'est-ce pas
c'est lui, ce
type,
ok, ok, arrête d'enregistrer pour la plupart, je vais
juste comprendre ce qui se passe
ensuite, est-ce qu'on le veut,
plus de camions, de gros camions s'arrêtent
ici, ne s'arrêtent pas